votre permis au premier constat
du médecin et vous devrez
êtes encore capables malgré tout
de conduire.
Jacques Bissonnet.
Automobile du Québec va
suspendre automatiquement
le permis de conduire d'une
personne souffrant de trouble
neurocognitif, qu'il soit léger
pouvait informer la SAAQ qu'un
détenteur de permi c c conduire
présentait un diagnostic
de trouble neurocognitif et
Mais le problème, c'est qu'en
attendant les résultats de cette
évaluation, il n'y avait pas de
révocation immédiate du permis.
GINO DESROSIERS, Soclelelelelelc
- Il y avait de la confusion.
d d d des gens qui conduisaient
quand même, en pensant qu'ils
pouvaient quand même conduire.
c'est que dès qu'on a un
diagnostic de trouble cogn
on suspend le permis
de la personne.
- Pour plusieurs médecins,
dont ce gériatre, cette mesure
Dr FADI MASSOUD, gériatre, CHUM
- Un des impacts, c'est que ça
va empêcher certaines personnes
qui en ont encore les capacités
de conduire un véhcececececececa
peut avoir sur leur autonomie
eueueueur qualité de vie.
- Ce médecin déplore aussi
le manque de communication
de la part de SAAQ.
si j'en suis, des patients qui
ont des troubles neurosssss
puis que les enjeux de conduite
automobile, ça fait partie de
rien reçu à cet effet-là.
e e e e e personne âgée,
c'est important encore d'avoir
autonome. C'est tout unobobobob.
- C'est la qualité de vie?
pas de trouble cognitif,
exprime très bien l'angoisse
de plusieurs personnes agées.
des questions de sécurité.- Pou,
je suis d'accord avec eux.
sévère avec cette mesure, en
disant qu'une tttttttttttteinte
de trouble neurocognitif et
qui vient de perdre son permutun
appeller de cette décision et
demander une nouvelle évaluation
de son état.
Radio-Canada, Montréa